Welcome to another deep dive.
Our goal, as always, is to cut
through all the noise, really
distill complex ideas and help
you get up to speed quickly but
also thoroughly.
Exactly.
Today we're jumping into
something pretty fascinating,
maybe a bit stark, actually.
An exploration of, well, the
shifting cultural and political
ground beneath our feet, you
could say.
And we're doing it through the
eyes of someone who calls
himself a watcher.
OK, let's unpack this.
Yeah, what makes this dive
really compelling, I think, is
the source material.
We've got two articles by Chris
Abraham, Order Lobster and The
Watcher.
They're pretty interconnected,
and they offer this really
distinct, maybe provocative
viewpoint is someone who sees or
perceives the Republic itself
as, well, collapsing.
Wow.
OK, so our mission today is
really to dig into that, extract
the core ideas, understand the
shifts in language and power
he's talking about, and explore
his pretty controversial thesis
about a quiet civil war.
And just before we really dive
in, it's super important we say
this upfront, right?
Our goal here is not to endorse
any of this.
None at all.
We're here to understand
Abraham's arguments, look at his
metaphors, his observations,
with total impartiality.
Just reporting what's in the
text exactly.
We want to give you, the
listener, maybe that a hot
moment, you know, a different
way to think about the stuff
swirling around in current
discourse.
It's definitely politically
charged content, no doubt.
So we're just laying out the
ideas from the source, trying to
give you the author's
perspective from different
angles so you can make up your
own mind.
We're here to distill
thoroughly.
OK, so let's start with Abraham.
Score stance.
How he sees himself in all this.
He's pretty clear from the
gecko, isn't he?
Yeah, he really is.
He says.
And I'm quoting.
I'm not calling for revolt or
secession or even policy.
I'm just watching.
Just watch.
It immediately sets him up as
this observer, maybe a detached
1 standing on the edge of what
he calls a Republic that doesn't
know it's collapsing.
He's not trying to push it.
Over No.
He's documenting the perceived
fall, and what makes his story
quite poignant, I think, is his
personal history with
institutions he feels have just
completely changed.
Right, the ACLU connection.
Exactly.
He talks about being a member of
the ACLU for a long time and it
for him back then it meant
defending free speech, period.
Even for people he found, you
know, repulsive.
Like his examples, Nazi, a
pornographer, a dissenter.
Yeah, he says, the principle of
speech mattered more than your
personal revulsion.
He joined, he insists, not for
virtue signaling or identity
building.
Right, not performative.
But as a pledge to the
Constitution, not the
performative one, but the dusty
one in the glass case, it paints
this picture of someone really
rooted in a traditional, almost
literal reading of those
founding principles.
And that's such a crucial setup
because what he's describing is
what he sees as a massive
institutional redefinition.
He claims these organizations,
like the ACLU, which he saw as
universalist, have basically
ditched their core principles
for partisan goals.
He says the ACLU now defends
rights selectively.
Implying they pick and choose
based on politics.
That seems to be his
interpretation, yeah.
And similarly, he says, the
Human Rights Campaign now
operates like APR arm of a
political faction.
So if we connect this to the
bigger picture he's painting,
it's not just about policy
changes.
It's deeper.
It's a fundamental shift in
meaning, a redefinition of core
terms.
Like the examples he gives?
Exactly.
Free speech is violence.
Silence is violence, but
apparently actual violence is
just passion.
He sees this inversion
everywhere.
Wow.
He's arguing the very concepts
we used to debate with freedom,
harm, expression.
They've been twisted, redefined,
maybe to the point where they've
lost their punch, their clarity.
So it creates this weird
linguistic fog.
Precisely where something
clearly wrong can be reframed as
OK and a right can be called
harmful.
This breakdown of language is
absolutely central to his whole
feeling of collapse.
And what I think makes his
Watcher persona feel well
earned, his narrative at least,
is how carefully he builds his
own credibility for it.
Yeah, he.
Lays out his background.
Right.
He really stresses he's not some
kind of red hatted reactionary.
He wants you to know.
He remembers a time when even
progressives believed in the
Bill of Rights.
He talks about growing up in
Hawaii, you know, surrounded by
all sorts of different people
culturally, politically.
But he felt they were still
mine, that sense of shared
identity.
That's a powerful phrase.
It is, and he mentions friends
in the DIA, the Defense
Intelligence Agency, his
closeness to Colonel Frank
Burns.
The Be All You Can Be guy talks
with Hope O'Keefe, this
constitutional lawyer he
admired, who he now sees
steering institutions he doesn't
recognize, not just politics.
For him, it feels personal, like
disillusionment.
It definitely as wait.
He's framing it as observing
from the inside out, or at least
from someone who used to feel
inside.
Exactly.
Not just an outsider lobbing
critiques.
Which then leads to this feeling
he describes of being sidelined.
Not attacked directly, maybe,
but quarantined.
Yeah.
Algorithmically sidelined.
Soft shadow band Bozo filtered
over his terms.
Let's quickly unpack those
algorithmically sidelined
platform algorithms.
Just kind of lower your
visibility, right?
Soft shadow bands, you're not
blocked, but nobody really sees
your stuff.
And bozo filtered.
That's an old Internet term.
Basically means the system just
ignores you your irrelevant
noise.
He even tells that story about
trying to get on the SPLC watch
list.
Yeah, the Southern Property Law
Center, he said.
The thought that he might be on
it, even if he was half joking,
stung because he felt yeah, I
was probably were true in their
eyes.
And he links this back to his
history, right?
His early Internet days.
Right spelunking down Internet
rabbit holes that the polite
world doesn't like to admit
exist.
That's quite a phrase.
It is from his time at places
like New Media Strategies,
founding meme space.
He knows Internet culture.
He's suggesting this is an old
school censorship.
It's quite quieter.
Digital exclusion.
Like a passive intellectual
exile.
Kind of your ideas just don't
make it into the acceptable
chat.
And this feeling of being pushed
aside connects directly to, I
think, one of his most powerful
points, the collapse of meaning
in words.
Yes, the language itself
breaking down.
He watches terms like racist,
which used to mean, you know,
burning crosses, get applied to,
well, him.
And he gives that very specific
self description.
Yeah.
A 55 year old, 6 foot three, 340
LB Jesus believing gun owner
with a lifetime NRA membership
and an ACLU card in my drawer.
He uses that to highlight the
perceived absurdity.
Right, and fascist being used
for parents at school board
meetings.
He says the spell is broken.
These words have lost their
power.
Which leads to that crucial
observation.
These labels used to be nuclear.
Now they're bumper stickers.
When everything is fascism,
nothing is.
When everyone is a bigot, no one
listens.
That really sums it up, doesn't
it?
Rhetorical inflation making real
critique impossible.
And he finishes that thought
with the public square is
broken.
The conversation is poisoned.
I haven't changed, but the rules
have feels incredibly personal
for.
Him.
It does.
And it's striking, isn't it, how
much he focuses on the power of
language and what happens when
that power gets diluted.
Because when racist or fascist
gets thrown around casually, the
words lose their edge.
Genuine, serious accusations
then struggle to land.
People become numb to it.
Exactly desensitized.
So the poison public square he
talks about, it's a place where
the shared vocabulary for debate
has just eroded.
It's replaced by this inflated
language that kind of ironically
makes everything less impactful.
It's like the tools of
communication are breaking.
That's a great way to put it.
If you can't even agree on what
words mean, how do you even
start to resolve anything?
It's a breakdown of the process
itself.
OK, so we've got this picture of
Abraham as the Watcher, seeing
language and institutions decay.
Now let's pivot to why he thinks
this is happening.
His idea of a cultural
revolution, which is really
summed up by that central
metaphor.
Ah yes, the order lobster
It's quite something.
It really is.
He lays it out like this.
The activist left was invited to
the table.
We said order anything you want.
The polite response would have
been to choose modestly, but
they ordered everything on the
menu. 3 lobsters, 4 steaks, 12
meals to go and when the check
came they demanded someone else
pay.
Wow, that's.
Direct it is.
It's obviously provocative, but
it's his analogy for what he
sees as a huge overreach by a
certain cultural political
group.
Not just disagreement, but
entitlement, taking everything
without considering the cost or
the initial offer.
Yeah, it frames it as this
really unbalanced deal.
Yeah.
And it sets up his argument
about perceived cultural
dominance.
That metaphor really captures
his view of what he calls a hard
revolution.
And if we connect this to the
broader picture, it's not just
about politics in the usual
sense.
It's about.
Culture.
Yeah, it's about achieving
cultural dominance.
Yeah.
He describes this revolution as
loud, moral, institutional,
uncompromising.
Not subtle then.
Not at all, he says.
It arrived through the front
door in broad daylight.
It came armed with slogans and
tenured allies, DEI statements
and HR policy changes,
intersectional theory and
protest theatre.
OK.
Let's pause on some of that DEI,
diversity, equity, inclusion,
those policies and companies,
universities.
Right, intersectional theory,
the idea that different identity
like race, gender, class overlap
to create unique forms of
discrimination or privilege,
often leading to calls for
specific actions and protest
theater, those big public, maybe
dramatic protests designed to
grab attention, which he seems
to view as somewhat
performative.
So he's painting this picture of
a very visible, very organized
push to change society from
within existing structures.
Exactly, using the tools of
institutions, academia, HR and
doing it with a strong sense of
moral certainty and no room for
compromise in his view.
And he gets specific about the
demands, doesn't he?
He does.
He says this revolution demanded
dismantling reeducation
reparations not just for systems
but for language itself.
So changing not just structures,
but how we think and talk.
Reshaping reality through
language.
That seems to be his
interpretation of the goal, yes,
a really fundamental ambition,
and he talks about the
confidence behind it.
Right, He says it pushed with
confidence because it had won
the culture war.
He saw the signals.
We run the campuses, we run the
platforms, we run the stories.
And because power flowed that
way.
It didn't need to ask, it told
that sense of achieved
dominance, meaning negotiation
is over.
Just think about that for a
second, you know, for you
listening, imagine how that
dynamic one side feeling, it
runs the show and sets the terms
might feel to someone who thinks
their own values are being
pushed aside.
Yeah, it definitely frames it as
a very one sided assertion of
power.
OK, now this is where Abraham's
story takes a really
interesting, maybe unexpected
twist.
After describing this hard
revolution, he talks about the
response from the right and he
argues it was totally different
from what the activists left
expected.
Right, he emphasizes the lack of
a symmetrical fight.
Exactly, he says.
Meanwhile, the right didn't
scream.
They didn't March on cities.
They just unplugged, defunded,
withdrew.
Quite a retreat.
He gives examples.
They didn't try to storm the
capital.
He seems to see Jan 6 as maybe
an exception, not the rule here.
Interesting point.
Instead he focuses on things
like they stop sending their
kids to your schools, they
started homeschooling, building
co-ops, decentralizing.
It's not a picture of fighting
back directly.
No, it's disengagement, a
strategic withdrawal.
It's almost like pulling back
from the mainstream.
And what's really fascinating is
how he frames this as strategic,
like a kind of judo move almost.
He insists there was no counter
revolution, no mobilization of
equal energy or symmetrical
confrontation.
He focuses on that group he
calls the Christian populist
nationalist segment, which he
knows gets lumped into mega, but
says it has a deeper, quieter,
more local spirit.
And his observation is key.
This group didn't fight the way
the left expected.
They took the hits, absorbed the
blows, got called names.
Racist, fascist, bigoted Hick.
He says they lost friends, jobs.
Right.
We're told their values were old
fashioned, their faith
dangerous.
And still, he claims they didn't
fight back in that expected
confrontational way.
They didn't regress.
They.
Remembered.
They remembered, yeah.
What does he mean by that, do
you think?
I think he means they drew on a
deep cultural memory on long
standing traditions rather than
just reacting politically.
It suggests resilience,
continuity, playing a long game.
So cultural preservation through
pulling back, not fighting head
on.
That seems to be his core
argument.
It's disarming because it's not
the expected counter attack.
Which brings us to that really
crucial distinction he makes
maintenance versus resistance.
Yes, this is central, he says.
What the left saw as resistance
was, from the right's
perspective, maintenance meaning
meaning it wasn't about pushing
back ideologically or trying to
go back to some dark past.
It was simply a refusal to
update the firmware.
Like to stick it with the
existing operating system.
Exactly.
Not launching a new movement,
just defaulting to what had
always been there.
And the examples he gives for
this are so every day.
It's so tangible.
They really.
Are the church potluck, the
homeschool Co-op, the second
freezer in the garage?
The .30 O 6 above the mantle.
The pickup truck with the cross
sticker.
The local sheriff, The farm
stand, The Bible on the bedside
table, The high school football
game where the entire town still
shows up.
These aren't political rallies,
they're just life, community,
tradition.
Precisely.
And he concludes, it wasn't a
political platform, it was a
culture.
And it hadn't died, just gone
quiet.
Suggesting it just retreated
from the spotlight, maybe went
underground in a way.
Yeah, or just focused inward
perhaps.
Which raises that big question,
doesn't it?
What are the actual long term
societal consequences if large
groups just disconnect like
that?
Right.
He hammers this point.
It wasn't backlash, it was
something more disarming.
Exit, Not revolt, but retreat.
Not destruction, but
disconnection.
The judo analogy comes back.
Right.
Let the overextension defeat the
attacker.
Use their momentum against them.
So the strategy is.
Let the screamers scream.
The Breakers break.
Meanwhile, stock the pantry, dig
in, wait.
It's about patience, long term
survival.
Why?
What's the end game?
His reasoning is starkly
practical because after the
fever burns itself out, someone
still needs to know how to
change a tire, clean a deer, fix
a roof, raise a child, pray over
the dead, and endure.
It's about basic resilience,
self-sufficiency.
Almost like preparing for a
different kind of future.
And that leads to his most
chilling line on this, I think.
They weren't planning to storm
your city.
They were planning to outlive
it.
Wow.
That paints a picture of a
really profound quiet divide,
generational endurance over
immediate conflict.
It's a strategy completely
outside the usual political
playbook.
OK, so this leads us to what he
calls the real civil war, but
he's very specific about what he
means by that, right?
Yes, absolutely.
Crucial distinction, he says.
It's quiet, economic, systemic.
Not tanks and trenches, no.
He states it bluntly.
Red America doesn't want to
invade blue America, it wants to
starve it.
It's a really harsh way to put
it.
Starve it how?
Economically, systemically,
through the flow of resources.
His suggested methods are things
like turn off the supply chains,
cut the water, defund the
grants.
So it's like a siege, but using
bureaucracy and finance instead
of weapons, leveraging
dependency.
That seems to be the idea and
the concept of indirect
defunding is really interesting.
Here he gives specific example.
Like public media?
Exactly.
He takes on the claim that NPR,
for instance, gets only 2% from
the government.
He calls that a joke for
insiders.
He says he's seen how the money
flows through CPBNEHNEAUSA.
He calls it a shadow subsidy.
OK CPB is Corporation for Public
Broadcasting, NEH.
National Endowment for
Humanities, NEH, AA, Arts USA.
Does international aid right.
How does that fit?
He's suggesting a complex web.
Even if direct funding is small.
These institutions rely on a
network of grants, indirect
support that ultimately traces
back to government sources, in
his view.
So his strategy isn't
censorship.
No, he implies.
That would look bad too.
Authoritarian instead.
It's don't censor it, just stop
funding the oxygen tanks.
Cut off the financial lifeblood
quietly.
Right, it shows an understanding
of those complex funding
streams.
Pull one thread and maybe the
whole thing unravels.
Let the him with or without a
direct attack.
And he applies a similar logic
to universities, doesn't?
He he does again, he says a
direct shutdown would look like
fascism, not the goal.
So what's the alternative?
Using existing legal tools, he
says.
But if you redefine their
excesses as anti-Semitism, which
many of them are now guilty of,
you can cut off federal grants
under Title 6.
OK, Title 6 of the Civil Rights
Act prohibits discrimination in
federally funded programs, and
that's been interpreted to
include anti-Semitism on
campuses.
Exactly.
So he's pointing to a legal
lever.
If campuses are found in
violation, their federal funding
can be cut.
So the tools aren't soldiers.
No, you don't need tanks.
You need accountants and lawyers
and parents who won't write
another tuition check.
Wow, it's all about financial
pressure points and legal
mechanisms using the system
against itself in a way.
That's precisely it.
Disrupt the money flow, not
directly control the message.
Aim for a slow systemic
weakening.
It's a very calculated, almost
cold strategy, avoiding direct
fights, aiming for deep change
through economics.
Definitely.
It implies that if you cut the
funding, the cultural stuff that
depends on it will just fade
away.
No need for censorship.
Economic attrition.
That's the term, and it raises
big questions about power.
Does he say how this plays out
long term?
Not in huge detail in these
pieces, but the implication is
clear cut.
The money and institutions
either change drastically or
collapse.
It's definitely a long game, and
notably, he doesn't really
explore potential blowback or
escalation from these kinds of
tactics.
His focus stays on the quiet
part.
OK, so next Abraham tries to
boil down the core values he
sees driving these two sides.
It's a stark simplification,
maybe, but interesting.
Yeah, he contrasts some quite
sharply.
He.
Says on one side, the left made
everything sacred.
Gender identity, racial
identity, pronouns, dietary
choices, even tone of voice.
Suggesting an ever expanding
list of things that are off
limits for debate, tied to
identity and expression, moving
beyond traditional ideas of the
sacred.
Right.
And then the contrast.
He says the right made nothing
sacred except autonomy.
Just one thing, individual
freedom, self governance, being
left alone.
That's a massive difference in
worldview, isn't it?
Huge.
And the implication he draws is
the right doesn't want control,
it wants distance.
Not about imposing their way,
but about separation.
Which brings up that question
again.
What happens when values clash
That fundamentally, when one
side keeps expanding the sacred
and the other sees that as
infringing on their only sacred
thing, autonomy?
Exactly.
It shrinks the common ground,
doesn't.
It makes compromise almost
impossible and fuels that desire
for distance, for exit rather
than trying to share control.
The tension comes from that
clash of what's ultimately
revered.
He uses that rubber band
metaphor here, doesn't he?
Yes, simple but powerful.
And if you push hard enough, if
you stretch the rubber band too
far, it doesn't snap back, it
breaks.
Suggesting it's not just a swing
back and forth, but a potential
structural failure, a permanent
break.
Right.
The constant pressure of
expanding sacredness versus the
defense of autonomy stretches
things to a breaking point.
And breaking for him seems to
mean that severing of
connections, that radical exit.
Not necessarily violence, but
separation, irreparable
division.
And he even applies a kind of
business analogy to the
movements themselves.
Yeah, he uses the old saying
some corporations have too many
chiefs and not enough Indians,
too much management, not enough
workers.
OK then, he says the Maggie, a
populist nationalist critique is
similar.
Too many vanguards, not enough
proletarians.
Vanguards being the leaders, the
theorists, proletarians the
working base.
Exactly.
He's pointing to a perceived
disconnect, the intellectual
leaders pushing agendas or ideas
that the actual base doesn't
fully connect with.
So the base might just disengage
turn out.
That seems to be the suggestion.
This top down feel alienates the
people it's supposed to
represent, maybe contributing to
that quiet exit, focusing on
their own lives instead of the
Vanguard's plans.
A gap between the theory and the
practice.
Hashtag tag of 6/6 the Watchers
final observations.
OK, so as we wrap up this deep
dive, Abraham comes back to
define himself one last time.
He states very clearly what he
is not.
Right, pushing back against the
labels.
I'm not a racist, I'm not a
sexist, I'm not a fascist.
I don't think I'm literally
Hitler.
It's a strong rejection of those
terms he sees is overused.
Then he says what he is.
I am something else.
I'm done pretending.
I don't see what's happening is
him reaffirming that role of
witness.
Not ideologue, not fighter, just
observer.
And cementing it.
Call it what you want, I'm just
the watcher.
There's a finality to that.
Or resignation maybe?
Bearing witness becomes his
primary act.
And the imagery he uses at the
very end, it's incredibly stark.
It circles back to that
restaurant metaphor.
Yeah, tell us about that closing
visual.
He paints this picture.
I see the restaurant going dark.
I see the check unpaid.
I see the waiter leaving.
I see the lights flicker.
It's just pure imagery of decay,
failure, system shutting down.
Like the whole enterprise is
collapsing.
Exactly.
But then comes the real kicker,
and I see the activists yelling
at the mirror, still arguing
over the pronouns on the dessert
menu.
Wow.
That's designed to provoke,
surely?
Oh absolutely.
It suggests this profound
unawareness, this focus on
internal, maybe trivial debates
while the whole structure is
failing around them.
Self absorption disconnected
from the reality of collapse.
A misplacement of priorities, in
his view.
That's the clear implication.
It brings his whole argument to
a sharp point.
And his final personal note
feels more sad than angry.
Doesn't.
It it does.
I love my country.
I love my friends, but I also
know when a party is over.
Acceptance.
Almost an end of an era.
Yeah, not a call to fight, but a
recognition that things have
fundamentally changed.
I'm not here to fight, I'm just
here to witness, to remember
what it used to mean.
The watcher holding on to the
memory, observing the fallout.
Chronicler, not combatant.
And then he leaves us, the
listener, with that final,
really potent question, the mic
drop moment.
Right.
What is it?
He says he's there to wonder
quietly after the last credit
card is declined, after the last
fund is frozen, if they'll ever
realize who was paying the bill
the whole time.
That's unsettling.
It implies a coming shock, a
revelation about where the
resources actually came from.
Exactly.
A challenge to perceived
self-sufficiency.
A hint that the support
structures were maybe invisible,
taken for granted and about to
disappear.
A rude awakening.
Hashtag Hatch outro.
So what does this all mean for
you?
Well, this deep dive into Chris
Abraham's perspective has
definitely given us a stark,
specific and, yeah, provocative
view on the cultural and
political shifts happening.
It's a challenging viewpoint.
He uses these really vivid
metaphors, personal stories, to
build this narrative of
disillusionment, quiet
withdrawal, and this idea of
strategic, systemic action
challenging how we usually think
about political conflict.
It certainly offers a unique
lens on fragmentation.
Apps.
Which leaves us with some pretty
big questions to Mull over,
doesn't it?
If this quiet Civil War idea
holds any water, if one side is
really focused on exit and
distance, what does that
actually mean for national unity
down the road?
Yeah, Can different groups ever
really share the same public
square again if the fundamental
values are so different and the
strategy is disengagement?
And what does autonomy truly
look like in a society that's so
interconnected?
Can you really disconnect
without creating massive real
effects for everyone?
Those are huge questions.
Definitely food for thought.
Extending way beyond just these
articles makes you reflect on
our shared spaces and what holds
things together, really.
Indeed, lots to think about.